I think it's really important to have some kind of routine...
...that you can count on from the minute you wake up in the morning.
So, that means setting an alarm.
If you don't get up at exactly the same time every day,...
...you wanna make sure it's somewhere around the same time every day.
I know it is so tempting to just sit around in your pajamas all day,...
...not get ready because, I mean, why not?
Doing something as simple as just getting dressed in like a t-shirt and jeans...
...will help you so much because that's almost like, your little work uniform.
This process makes me feel more put together and I'm able to separate...
..."I am working and getting stuff done"...
...from "I'm comfy and cozy in my pajamas watching Netflix."
When you have your designated workspace, it almost becomes like your little office...
... within your home.
So when you walk into that space, you subconsciously know...
...I am turning on for work right now.
This is my work zone.
And when you step out of that space, it's like, "Okay, I'm finished working...
...and now, I am stepping into my life."